[Music]
tuatanga vailo the fifth overall pick in
the 2020 draft to the miami dolphins
kind of a surprise because the dolphins
did a good job of keeping quiet about
their intentions nick saban tonga by low
as head coach at alabama was not quiet
about his praise of tua he basically
said hey look if you don't take tua
you're making a mistake on the level
that i made in 2006 when i said no thank
you to drew brees so
the dolphins who were the team that
saban was working for when they said no
thank you to drew brees heeded that
warning and now
and now
now that he's drafted nick saban is
singing a slightly different tune here
are quotes to the miami herald earlier
this week the number one thing we've
tried to convince tua of is he's got to
learn self-preservation as part of the
job tua is a great competitor you don't
want to take his competitive spirit away
he's always trying to make a play even
when the play breaks down and that's
good he does it well he makes a ton of
plays in the circumstances but i still
think there are times when there's just
nothing there several times when he's
got hurt here i felt like there's no
reason for him to even get hit
now look that that cuts against the
phrase that saban gave to tour and i
don't know how much of that can be taken
out of who a guy is you know sims has
said that when he looked it to his film
there were so many times where tour got
hit in an awkward way that made sims
think he's not getting up and he managed
to get up but you get hit in awkward
ways like that on a regular basis at the
nfl level you ain't getting up so you
know uh
a big part of being an effective
quarterback in the nfl is being able to
show up and play and i don't care how
good tua is when he plays if he plays in
a way that jeopardizes his ability to
play that to me is a red flag that's
exactly why there was talk of him
sliding out of the top ten big cat
yeah i i know what you're saying by the
way the nick saban uh
picture there that's from like 25 years
ago love that love that make sure that
you always use the youngest picture but
i i know exactly what you're saying mike
but don't you think that there's an
element that wants to against the nfl
and everything's faster stronger
bigger
it's going to be a little more
self-preservation remember he's playing
at alabama that was so much better than
almost everyone they played for to his
entire stretch as his college career
that
going out there and saying i am superman
i can take the hits i can stand in the
pocket a little extra and let these guys
come after me probably gets in your
brain because you say i got i got just
dudes everywhere to left of it to the
right so it's i i i wouldn't say that he
can't completely eliminate that from his
game because he did it in college i
think playing for alabama having that
superhero feel to him having the ability
to have a you know an offensive line in
front of you studs on the outside and be
like we're superman we're going to just
dominate everyone
that's going to change once he gets the
nfl and things move a little bit faster
and i think the challenge is
adjusting that clock in your head
without getting to the point where you
have the yips essentially where and and
you know sims and i've had this
conversation about eli manning in the
latter years of his career when he had
no protection the clock accelerated for
him he was making decisions faster than
he would have because he had to assume
the walls were going to slam shut within
two or three seconds instead of within
four or five seconds and there were
times he'd throw the ball where he
wasn't in any physical danger but and
that's going to be the challenge for tua
understanding i have to know
where that sweet spot is to get rid of
the football and i have to time it right
and here's the problem i think a lot of
it's instinctive big cat and that's my
concern you develop your muscle memory
you develop your sense of how your body
operates in relation to everyone else's
and now all of a sudden you're making a
dramatic change to that
and you become someone who is more
cautious with your body
it's important that he does that i just
don't think it's something that you can
say oh that's what i need to do oh okay
i'll go do it
yeah i i still love the pick for the
dolphins i think two is special i i get
the concerns i also love that nick saban
is doing a great job of hedging like you
said
everyone was saying you know you have to
he was telling everyone before the draft
if you don't pick two it's the biggest
mistake you ever made then the draft
happens he says well he's got to stay
stay healthy so that's a smart edge on
his part so that he doesn't look foolish
if tua gets hurt right away but i i
still love the pick for the dolphins and
and and the dolphins
the the rebuild they have done in a very
short period of time and you could make
the argument that they've been kind of
rebuilding for a long time because they
haven't had a guy behind center that
they've trusted since dan marino but
what they've done in the last two years
has been i think very impressive and i
do think they're going to be one of
those teams that's going to be frisky
next year and you saw them fight for
brian flores and they've kind of remade
what they're going to do and how they
want to do it pretty quickly here
um i i just i i'm tipping my cat because
it's hard to do in the nfl and it feels
like they've done a pretty good job with
it
and i think they also sold the owner on
taking the risk with tua because the
owner wanted joe burrow i know that for
a fact he wanted joe burrow they tried
to move up to get joe burrow when the
bengals consistently say no no no no no
well the owner still wants a franchise
quarterback so if you can't get borough
who's next and it's either justin
herbert or it's tuatonga viloa the team
decided it's tua and hey if it doesn't
work it's just the latest failed
dolphins quarterback since dan marino
but i think ross as he turns 80 on may
10th i believe he he wants to have a
franchise quarterback to carry him
through this next decade which i mean
let's let's be realistic it may be the
last decade he owns the team so uh i
think that was part of the motivation
they want a franchise quarterback they
couldn't get borough they're rolling the
dice with tua and they're hoping that
this time around the football gods will
give them craps when craps is good i
never know when craps is good sometimes
it's good sometimes it's bad it's been
bad for the dolphins for a long time
they're hoping that craps turns out good
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports